-Performing "People"
from the hit Broadway revival
of "Funny Girl,"
please welcome Lea Michele.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ We travel single, oh ♪
[ Chuckles ]
♪ Maybe we're lucky ♪
♪ But I don't know ♪
♪ With them,
just let one kid fall down ♪
♪ And seven mothers faint ♪
♪ I guess we're both happy ♪
♪ Maybe we ain't ♪
♪♪
♪ People ♪
♪ People who need ♪
♪ Are the luckiest people ♪
♪ In the world ♪
♪♪
♪ We're children ♪
♪ Needing other children ♪
♪ And, yet,
letting a grownup pride ♪
♪ Hide all the need inside ♪
♪ Acting more like children ♪
♪ Than children ♪
♪♪
♪ Lovers ♪
♪ Are very special people ♪
♪ They're the luckiest people ♪
♪ In the world ♪
♪ With one person ♪
♪ One very special person ♪
♪ A feeling deep in your soul ♪
♪ Says you were half ♪
♪ Now, you're whole ♪
♪ No more hunger and thirst ♪
♪ But, first, be a person ♪
♪ Who needs people ♪
♪ People who need people ♪
♪ Are the luckiest people ♪
♪ In the world ♪
♪ A feeling deep in your soul ♪
♪ Says you were half ♪
♪ Now, you're whole ♪
♪ No more hunger and thirst ♪
♪ But, first, be a person ♪
♪ Who needs people ♪
[ Applause ]
♪ People who need people ♪
♪ Are the luckiest people ♪
♪ In the ♪
♪ World ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughs ]